- [Instructor] In previous
videos, we started talking about
the idea of transformations.
In particular, we talked
about rigid transformations.
So for example, you can shift something.
This would be a translation.
So the thing that I'm moving
around is a translation
of our original triangle.
You could have a rotation.
So that thing that I
translated, I am now rotating it
as you see right over there.
And you can also have a reflection.
The tool that I'm using doesn't
make reflection too easy.
But that's essentially
flipping it over a line.
But what we're going to
talk about in this video
is a non-rigid transformation.
And what makes something
a rigid transformation
is that lengths between
points are reserved.
But in a non-rigid transformation,
those lengths do not need to be preserved.
So for example, this rotated
and translated triangle
that I'm moving around right
here, in fact I'm continuing
to translate it as I talk.
I can dilate it.
And one way to think about
dilation is that we're just
scaling it down or scaling it up.
So for example, here,
I am scaling it down.
That is a dilation.
Or I can scale it up.
This is also a dilation or even going off
of the graph paper.
So the whole point
here's just to appreciate
that we don't just have
the rigid transformations,
we can have other types
of transformations,
and a dilation is one
of them in your toolkit
that you will often see,
especially when you get introduced
to the idea of transformation.